all right hello everyone we are doing a
design review for Wilson language
version 13.2
um of astronomy functionality and this
is uh part three of a series dealing
with a fairly major new area of
functionality
so
um
Let's uh let's get started here so what
which function are we starting on
um Astro position is a fundamental
object first
okay
and so if I say for example here
um
excuse me uh
all right so if I say just like Astro
position
of
Pluto
what's happening right now
the first time it has to load the system
do we want to put a progress monitor
thing there
um we're good
good all right we've we've already
talked about these negative things being
wrong and the icon being wrong right yes
so I don't what could be a good
suggestion for an icon yeah
I don't know why don't we get the design
people in here I mean I I think
that's too cutesy way too cute see
what do we have for geo position
for your position the thing is that with
a single position we don't have anything
and with multiple positions we show the
points
okay
the thing is that this has a lot of
information inside so it's not so nice
to show I don't understand why we don't
just show a basic
you know
projection with a point yeah I mean or
something we just don't want something
QC like this there's no value to
cutesyness here I also think well let's
say north south north azimuth
because asimus can be measured from
North and from South
let's do this ambiguate that but what's
the default
the default is not
but don't people usually say as it is an
altitude and don't they usually mean
in general they mean North but there are
cases in which itself okay but but we
don't want to put in everybody's dangle
under everybody's nose something like
that here we want to keep this as simple
as possible okay
I mean is the frame really the top thing
or should it be the bottom thing
I think it's the most important thing
for what's the reference frame you are
using and also this font is too big here
yes that no
it is the default type setting of dates
but the distance seems very relevant
here
I mean honestly it's like these are
these are spherical coordinates radius
and these are Theta Phi
I would just say
you know I would say distance Azimuth
altitude because honestly the Azimuth
and altitude unless you're actually
manhandling your telescope or something
you're probably not going to really care
what those are those are just yep okay
they're numbers that's good I mean think
of Geographics and Astro uh position or
Astro Graphics as being basically 2D
systems in which case distance is really
just meta information because it's a 2d
system so is it if you think of it as
well yeah I mean Geographics is 2D it's
not 3D same thing with Astro Graphics
is the Stars so for many objects we
don't have a distance and we just place
them in the celestial sphere so distance
we always have the the two angles but
not always don't we know the distance to
the Stars
some of them
we know parallax
yes not for all of them for some of them
The Parallax angle is too small to
measure hmm
okay
I want to say Hubble I'm sorry
um a hipparcos in the early 90s I think
it was limited to something like 900
light years and beyond that the uh
Parallax angle became so small became
highly error-prone so anything beyond
that was not really easily measurable
okay
so but if I say
there's an is there an astral distance
uh yes you can compute asteriskness
between two objects
well so if I just say astral distance
you know
Pluto
I'm not sure we have information for for
cities
okay downloading it
wow okay now what happens if I want to
know what it is next week
um in this add a date in the third
argument
nice
uh
I thought this would work it should
okay all right fine
okay
um is that documented to work
uh not yet no
I think it should work because like it's
something people are gonna routinely
want I don't sorry I don't think I have
a a reference page for us to listen yet
okay
okay
now what you can do
is extra position
by the way sorry astral distance of one
argument
yes should is presumably the distance
from the center of the earth is that
correct
I think so is it this is who are
distance from the center of the Earth
I think it defaults
I think it defaults to your actual
position okay fine
okay
and so then the the other case is I mean
you should be able to say dated of blah
right so we should be able to say
something like Astro position dated
comma whatever it is
yeah as I think this works yet but yeah
I think it should work okay fine
I mean does does
um
no I don't mean Astra position I mean
well astral position of data it should
work as well but I mean Astrid distance
here
foreign
okay
wow okay so if I say this for
um
try now are dating the second argument
by the way by the way I just want to
report the bug you see this this is off
center
you know I'm at 150 magnification and
this thing is off center
Aubrey that's for you please
don't you think we should just return it
in light years
um yes I think so actually try as the
position of Betelgeuse
okay
and by the way why that for goodness
sake somebody needs to fix that
autocomplete
okay I see yeah it seems alphabetic yeah
yeah it's completely wrong right so can
somebody please get that right Aubry
please report that
that's good it's far away it might blow
up soon
okay
so let's try yeah try extra position of
Beetlejuice I think it does convert into
light years in astral position
but I can't see
it's called parsecs actually changes to
kilo per second I see it's not great I
mean I think you should just with astral
distance you should just since it's got
units you should just make it be
reasonable units
yes it's just that astronomers at some
point change immediately to per second
parsecs rather than than lagios
yeah well fine but I mean then then they
yeah he uh personally light years light
years are more useful than uh parsecs in
my opinion
yeah and and the entity the star entity
is usually light years as well for
distance from Earth
check the chat window for an example
okay
so you know be nice if that's consistent
with each other but what they're not
choices yeah okay all right okay let's
let's look now um so we've been looking
previously at Astro
position have we finished looking at um
no it has many freedoms and um okay
let's take a look
okay
if we just are treating this as Azimuth
altitude and it's the northern Azimuth
or whatever then you know we should just
say Azimuth here because this is
confusing
okay yep
okay
okay
so
what's that I want to see what's at null
Island in space
what the heck is that
um that's um yes
that's had to do for me to do something
there
okay
um
where am I storing these things
do we have an astronomy area here
I don't think we do yeah okay
let's start it off
what what should that have been
uh it's serious it's still internally
um zero zero so it's it's your North
it's Azimuth altitude should be
okay so now how do I find the star
that's closest to that
so if you say for example as the
position of North should get the same
thing
this is broken in some way
yes I think so uh it should have
returned
so try this thing North well I mean I'm
trying to understand what oh I see
okay that works so there's a minor
glitch there okay so now I want to know
what's the closest star
um
interesting I I don't we don't have a a
function to compute that yet
okay
okay can I make an astro Graphics of
right around that area
um well let's try astrographics so it
may be broken index can I have been
changing it a lot faster Graphics a
bracket bracket
and let's see what happens yep
it's working
it's not it is working or it's not
working no no it's not working it's not
showing anything like that okay do you
want to share your screen
um yes I can okay now we're going to go
back to astral position yep
okay go ahead
okay
so um so this is the graphics
and um
could you make that bigger so I can I
just yes it's actually it's between make
that particular image bigger yep
okay
so so those are the brightest stars
sorry
um sorry I I have something else
so let me let me do this again
yes so by default it shows the about a
thousand stars and it labels about 20 of
them
the brightest ones the brightest ones
yes and so the idea is that zero zeros
here it's north then that's Polaris so
right above here we'll go over Polaris
for a second go Mouse to Polaris okay so
it's going okay okay Polaris
and that's yeah so those are equatorial
coordinates and we should use quantities
and then it's a magnitude 1.97 okay but
so it needs to say magnitude or
something exactly yes yes how do you
usually notate that
100.
magnitude just uh okay
and 6200 that's effective temperature
then for goodness sake it should say
kelvins yep yep and if we wanted to be
cute we'd color the color of that
effective temperature
yes in fact the stars have have a color
it is they are very small but they are
colored with their no I'm saying that
the actual if we wanted to be cute mouse
over we color the 6200 kelvins with the
color yeah um and let me cool the mouse
over again please
over again okay the border is way too
thick
I also think that the background should
not be not be black
let me ask somebody from design about
that please yep
um
so this has a label for about 20 stars
and then the other ones there are about
a thousand okay can you show me um I
mean uh can you show me Mars Mouse over
Mars please
[Music]
but it should it should do that and the
moon as well and everything yeah exactly
yes okay so these these this is the
Horizon so this line This horizontal
line is the ground
okay wait a minute you had grid lines
previously but you don't anymore yes I
had some sort of
um default setting but uh we cannot
that's true
create
plans
yeah I'm a little bit concerned about
the data size when you have all of those
um tool tips not sure how useful all the
the you know the the random little
tooltips in um
uh
no end up being and I I'm not sure that
that's
I I don't know you should figure out
whether there's a data size problem
it could be something that you obtain
rather than
um having them by default
yeah
so then this the moon and the sun are
visible they are enlarged they are
um
in actuality they are smaller
I don't understand the grid lines why is
that why is that the correct project I
mean are those lines of altitude and
Azimuth yes
okay
and so altitude 0 is this line so we are
thinking of actually coloring this part
darker or something like that to
represent this is the ground this is the
part you don't see
yes
I mean I would sort of gray it out
somehow I'm not sure do we have anybody
from design and we need some different
design to look at that I mean I would I
would think that what you want to do
let's see how to do that I mean you've
already got black
this is a design problem I mean should
we should we find somebody from design
for this meeting which we have them in
this meeting or should we uh collect
pieces
um
and I I think we should focus perhaps on
the physics and data science
so this is a design item Aubrey please
make sure that maybe towards the end of
the meeting we can pull Jeremy or
somebody else from designing and go
through these
okay
so one question is what to show by
default there are multiple things that
we could show and so here I have some
defaults and when I activate this then
we will get something bigger and we will
get also some lines
which are the the fundamental planes
and so it takes time because it's
processing the background image
image up there I mean nothing's you know
there's a background when nothing is
moving right they're the fixed Stars
but but it is moving because we are
looking from the earth and so this whole
thing is rotating if we look at it
sometime later it will be rotated I
understand but so what transmission on
that image is being made to represent
that rotation
it's it's performing both a rotation of
the earth and then it's performing some
corrections by various things like
refraction things like that so it's it's
doing non-trivial image processing on
that background image absolutely yes
and there's a significant I mean is it
visible that things like refraction
Corrections
um some are divisible yes like
preposition refraction can be up to what
a degree or so yeah on the horizon yeah
but I mean can we okay listen you need
to make that faster
I mean in in um
for example a way to see the the
difference is us through a background
goes to Black so with this I remove the
image and just make it something black
so you saw the difference between the
computation of the image and with the
image and without the image
okay
and so here we see some lines now with
with white sorry with a black background
they are kind of thinner
um
so this is the ecliptic so this is the
path where
you will find the sun and the planet so
there's some Uranus Jupiter Saturn moon
so they are all along this line
then we have here the the brown line is
the plane of the Galaxy
and then the purple line
which is here too is the equator of the
Earth
the projection out of the Equator of the
Earth
sorry which line
yes it's it's not very visible line
it's um for some reason when I activate
the black background it looks um
uh kind of less visible
so you see the lines there yeah but
where's the the ground is the Blue Line
because I don't think these I I think
these
I don't know how to gray down the the
lower half but we need a way to do that
yeah um
and I think these colors are a little
bit random
yes
I mean the plane of the ecliptic seems
to me if anything should be should be a
yellowish color to indicate the Sun
that's what I'm saying green is not why
is green the color of the ecliptic I
think green should be the Horizon
because that sounds like grass
fine
and um all right so the plane of the
ecliptic I think should be yellowish
color and you've got another thing which
is the projection of the Equator of the
Earth
right right so there are four main
planes
and so for example if we do this other
computation now in Equatorial
coordinates now the the plane that
becomes flat is the equatorial plane
okay I think that should be a dotted
line of some kind
the equator
I don't know why but that's I mean it's
kind of like actually I mean on on
Globes don't you see
I'm forgetting I haven't looked at the
globe recently enough but there's
there's some conventions for how the
equator is indicated on the globe
I see
but I think a dotted line is an
appropriate thing okay so is there a
fourth one of these lines here
therefore so the plane of the Galaxy
that you see it's aligned with the
Galaxy and goes through the center of
the Galaxy here
then there there is the ecliptic the
equatorial plane that they they cross in
the equinoxes so that's the auto
mechanics and that's the
sorry no that's the Spring Equinox and
that's the auto mechanics which we just
passed so the sun is very close to it
and then this is the the horizontal
plane
so these three are essentially fixed
this one is rotating
I understand but but also we need a I
mean the color that you're using there
for the Milky Way that seems okay I
don't know ask and now that's another
design item please
something me and Jose discussed is
whether or not we want to
equirectangular to be the default
projection for this Horizon system
because if you are like if you made this
a the default would be looking at the
Zenith Your Horizon would just be at the
edge it would just be a circular region
right do you have that example Jose
um yes
I think then you wouldn't have to worry
about shading out the uh area below it
because you would only be seeing the sky
above you
yes so we're having discussing having
maps of this kind in which
um you see the sky around your area you
know that is the much more familiar
Astro map
isn't it
um yes yes there's a tendency to use
asimota projections with uh with the
Stellar Maps yeah
I mean that's what one normally sees
I think there's an argument for using
this one by default now let's talk about
the framing of this could you make it a
little bit smaller so we can see the
full frame
why is it dragging so much when it gets
changes the image is launched and it has
thousands of points with two types and
color or something
okay
why is that minus one minus minus two
minus one what the heck does that mean
these are the projection these are the
coordinates projection which is
traditionally
down from minus two to two
but those are irrelevant it's a relevant
yes
and and on the left hand side they're
also part of the actual numbers of
projection so so basically we should
just have this without frame
yeah
that seems right to me and I think
having a a tool tip on the
grid lines might be useful
I see yes
I much prefer this to the the um
equirectangular
okay
and I see so you're asking also the
question do we actually want the
cuteness of that background I think it's
nice to have that background uh Milky
Way
we were thinking perhaps of having some
sort of vector approximation so that it
shows in this
faster Maps yes why not
you don't need I mean yes I think that's
a good idea one point of clarification
here Jose so right now we're looking
essentially is this centered on your
Zenith is that correct
no the signals will be this one so this
is this is the horizontal plane so this
is a below ground this is above ground
right because you're seeing the South
you're seeing the South this is the
entire sky right this is the entire Sky
yes yeah I don't think that's what we
want so we could cut it here which is
what you're saying to yeah yeah I think
yeah the Horizon should be it should
match up with the circle you see here
the visible area should be your horizon
I think I see yeah so I think I remember
what the word you were saying before so
so the what you want is to Center the
sky at the um at the North which I think
is here
um centering
and um
then we want to only show
um
so we want from 0 to 90
.
and we want to just draw
no I think this is already
so it's something this is the
right so now this is just sinus and this
is the ground
I don't know but Jeff should say
but this seems more sensible to me I
mean this is what you actually see in
the sky
now all that stuff that is outside of
the disc I don't think we should show
that yes this is not doing proper
keeping
but it should
okay but so we want you know the things
you've shown as these examples
there should be some very easy way to
set one option
to um
uh to get to the the three cases that
you're showing here this one here
because you've got a scroll up you've
got like a zoo of options here yeah
um
so what's the I mean what's the sort of
Bank switch version of this that you
want
this is kind of like
um
I mean do you want a second argument to
Astro Graphics that just says one of you
know just has string values
it's one of several string values or
something
I would like to keep the parallelism
with graphics and Geographics in the
sense that it's always Primitives and
options we could have something like
astral range goes to
up Hemisphere or even astrographics up
Hemisphere and it shows directly this
well you're you're saying just like we
have in the case of we have a primitive
in Geographics right angiographics you
can do something like world
and then it will show the wall map so we
could say Astro graphics
of sky
wouldn't this just be a plot theme
no that that would more be more like
controlling colors and other things this
is just the the area you want to show
and then astrographics will choose
automatically the best I might say so
the sky is up
yes but I mean there is a complementary
part to this
which is down the sky below you I I
understand that the sky is not you know
accepting Greek mythology or something
the sky is not below you
the sky is up
I mean we could have something like a
local sky or something but I think we
should just say astral Graphics of sky
astral Graphics of like celestial sphere
or some such other thing is the case of
the full
of all around is that right is that the
right usage
uh yes this is the full celestial sphere
so this is north and all these points
are South
right I'm saying that as a name it's
like astrographics of sky
blump
or astrographics of like local sky or
something might be better Astro Graphics
of celestial sphere
okay does that make sense
um
and
then maybe we want
Astro Graphics okay so those Define
okay now we want to be able to say
easily the different ways that this um
um
it's very common to want to turn on
different coordinate grids
even if you've got just your Sky your
local Sky showing you may want to see
the equatorial grid overlaying on top of
your local sky
yes I I was planning to do this via
Astro
create lines and then you say here are
the videos equatorial
and right
and have the lines there I I didn't
understand could you say that again Jeff
so it's quite common let's say you're
looking at just your local sky so your
horizon is the edge of the disk that
you're seeing but you want to turn on
different grid lines I mean by default
it's fine to show altitude and Azimuth
but you may want to see equatorial in
other words you want to see the grid
lines coming from Polaris
right because if you have a telescope
that's tracking the sky it's going to
follow the celestial equator not your
altitude and Horizon
right so right now it it's showing
always the asteroid lines Associated to
the celestial system that you preferred
here
but yeah I I was planning to to activate
all of them separately and use you can
specify here the standard
um
specs for uh
or a grid lines okay but hold on the
this Lambert as a New Soul
is this
I mean
that's the name that that projection
would have in the geoprojection but what
is its name in astronomy I don't know
that it's commonly used it I mean they
use the same projections it's just that
they use a different set by default for
example for maps of the Galaxy the
standard one is mobile
but that's the the same name sorry
that's the same name in the in the Astro
community
okay but what's what's the name yeah
I've seen that one right but what's the
name for this
um I'm I'm confused here the fact that
we're calling it Lambert has a beautiful
doesn't
won't most astronomers be what the heck
is that
yes there's quite a few projections that
I don't think astronomers even used so
that's why but hold on but that's one
we're using as a default so what would
the astronomer call that they call it a
an azimuthal projection or what would
they call it or would they not even
discuss the fact that it's a projection
it does appear it does appear in
in books
um I mean the there are multiple
asymmetal projections and and perhaps
another one like there is a
stereographic too let's say I mean which
one do people usually use
um
I think we need to know the answer to
that so that we know which one to make
the default
what does stereographic look like here
that's funky yep
so in the stereographic projections
planes are either circles or lines
so this is cool yeah okay
boy this fears are complicated things
okay
yeah this one
okay but I just want to know which one
is is the default I mean which one is
the astronomer's default and how do they
refer to it
I I would say that probably this type of
View using as the mutual Equity distance
could be the nicest thing okay let's see
it
so the nice thing of this one is that
these intervals have the same distance
in lamberta simultaneous they get
shorter and shorter okay well then let's
use this I mean let's decide what the
what the default is and use it I mean
yep and um
but we probably need some astronomy
friendly names for okay let's go back
and look at these options again for a
second here please
okay
okay this Astro Observer thing I'm not a
big fan of that name
so what's in that bucket
so this is the second argument of Astra
position effectively this what we have
here is an observation and this is
defining who and in which orientation
is observing and when
so you can specify the orientation the
date the location you can say here or
some other point of the Earth or
whatever and then there are parameters
are you using reflection
are you considering
light time and so it will compute the
positions of things when they emitted
the light
and things like that deflection because
this thing shouldn't be itself a ahead
of a head
like an observer something that's true
extra frame I call it a frame sometimes
or it's also sometimes referred to as a
reference system
I don't like the name Astro Observer
because not least because I've been
working on this thing I'm calling
Observer Theory but that's which is not
completely unrelated but it's a little
bit bizarrely different
um
uh
we already have a symbol that might be
reusable here which is this one
um
what does that even mean in that case
it's the same thing it's just that it
has only two possibilities Horizon and
equatorial
and now we have like 12 plus options
Celestial system sounds like something
Kepler would have written about
we're gonna lay our system of the world
or something
uh
let's see what really is this this is
I mean it's very similar to the
viewpoint
and things
um
and you know in 3D Graphics how what
will be the analog and 3D Graphics of
this
I mean that boils down the questions
what is this thing actually doing is it
defining your origin is it defining what
is it actually setting what is Black's
Viewpoint it's the Viewpoint and look
this has the analog of
it has the relativistic analog of view I
mean Viewpoint is the here
Horizon what is the analog of that in um
uh so because we are always on this fear
of the Earth
we have to specify whether we are
looking
from the center of the Earth
or from a point on the surface or do we
follow the rotation of the earth is
still with us or did Roger drop out the
project no no I'm I'm here
okay so in the case of 3D Graphics what
is the analog of what we're talking
about here because Viewpoint there's a
Viewpoint and a View Center right in 3D
graphics
yeah so
well Viewpoint is a little special
because that's that's the old old camera
model that we have and it implicitly
when you set Viewpoint you need to be
outside of the things you're viewing
kind of like a microscope
so what is our new way of doing this so
there is view vector
which is the projected vector
The View Vector says where you're
looking at then you have to set the view
angle separately
the angle view angle gets computed
automatically when you use Viewpoint to
always include the whole world so to
speak the whole problem I understand but
so these things view vector and view
angle should be relevant also for Astro
Graphics should they not
yeah it's just a question of what the
convention is so I I understand but they
Define a viewport basically yeah looking
at the sky yeah
okay I mean and and perhaps we should
even support them in Astro graphics
unless that's crazy
well in a sense this is trying to
imitate what you would see while in
Astro in Geo we are always going to
deform it with a projection
I see let's see I see so so this is not
something you see yeah okay at that
point now I mean an interesting question
is
why are we never doing that for graphics
I mean in other words
when we have spherical image
okay if I'm looking at an object
if I were looking through a fisheye lens
I will be distorting it in the kind of
way that we're distorting it for astral
Graphics correct yep
I'm sure there is a projection that
imitates that
right but is it the case Roger that in a
3D scene we could imagine a situation
where we would make
a a geographics-like projection of the
3D scene yes presumably yes I mean just
like you look at the Earth and you
project it you're looking at a 3D object
and you can project it
I mean we are projecting it it's just we
use it no no I know we use a single
projection I'm saying that we you know
is it possible that we could support
what will be the way that you would take
the 3D I'm just a little bit confused
about sort of you know because in 3D we
have depth you know when you think of
something you're looking at the Earth
but there's no depth it's just a sphere
no no no no but but the point Roger is
this when you look from a point
when you look at the Earth yeah the
depth is your distance to a particular
point on the Earth from where you are I
think
right it's it's defined only by the
shape of the Earth
yep
but then
the projection the reason the projection
is not trivial and something like an
um what is it called um
Ortho what the heck is that called
what's the graphic orthographic
projection right right
that's just taking parallel lines is it
not from where you are to the Earth
ignoring the depths right
yes so this is a family of projections
which are the perspective projections
which is which are the ones imitating
what you would see
and so when you go to Infinity when the
perspective is from Infinity you get the
orthographic projection right and that's
we use those prospective projections
that's what we use that's what the
normal I'm saying that there's there's
nothing that would I mean it is a Pity
that things are not modular enough that
we can take our geoprojections and apply
them to a 3D scene
right why would you
um
well why would you want it
uh immediately I you know it depends if
you if you've got something where
you know let's say you've got a robot
and it's in the center of some Block
World
you know we are so used to the fact that
we have eyes only in the front of our
heads so to speak that we're used to
seeing you know we're not used to seeing
this picture that you know Jose is
showing on the screen here which is a
you know because you need eyes in the
back of your head to see that whole
image there isn't this kind of what view
Matrix is used for I've never used view
Matrix but uh well it's it's an encoder
no it isn't you can't do this
few matrixes only is a global
transformation
yeah view Matrix basically is that
projection perspective you know you can
do actually you can do both perspective
and orthographic with it
so so one of the advantage of the
geoprojections is that they they show
you the whole world at the same time
by the way I hate the size of the labels
here these labels are twice the size
they should be
I just want to say that okay
actually Stephen speaking to your use
case I mean I think it's
still a marginal use case but
um
autonomous driving you know like a Tesla
car has eight cameras
um
and but they usually literally show the
eight views at the same time
uh
well yeah look I mean even
you know my current car has a has some
camera somewhere and when you park it
it'll show you the as if view from above
your car I have that too it's great
actually
um
and that's obviously doing some
projection you know
um
I'm trying to remember what that Tesla
that I was driving
um
uh I don't think it shows it in the car
in the car in the car visualizations but
when they showed then they give talks
and stuff that's what they usually show
just the eight views
the eight views yeah
and then you have how that streams into
maybe a what they call the vector space
which is not a vector space in a
mathematical sense it just means vector
graphics yeah Vector 3D graphics
um but this thing of having multiple
kind of uses synthesizing it up I guess
it's kind of maybe growing
maybe right but I mean look I'm just I'm
just trying to orthogonalize this
functionality that we have right yeah it
is the case that this notion of
projecting
could work for any 3D graphic
we are doing it currently for
the celestial sphere and the geosphere
so to speak
I'm just I'm just making that point I
mean somebody could make a you know a
wfr thing as a test case to make a a
projection of an arbitrary 3D scene well
maybe it should be the other way around
that Astro you know Geo and Astra should
be modernized so you can actually see
what you're looking at right now you
somehow we see everything
which is a bit weird
well look once we have spherical image
that clearly should be a way to turn
a an astro Graphics into a spherical
image
which in turn should be projectable into
VR
I mean it should be the case that any of
these Astro Graphics things are easy to
you know
render in VR
right so that because in the end
you know as you say you know in VR
that's the full object that you're going
to be seeing that that astral Graphics
you know uh Circle there it's a full
object you're going to be seeing except
that at any given moment with your gaze
in a particular direction you only see a
small part of that
that makes sense
so I mean the point that you're making
Roger is there could be if we have a
model for the viewer that is of the
viewport type right the kind that we
have for 3D Graphics then there is a
viewport that you can superimpose on
this on that image could you re-render
that so it isn't Gray
um
all right change this to
okay so that's an additional thing is
essentially the viewport on this right
that makes sense to people
and arguably we should support that and
that viewport just like it is what
actually happens when you look through a
telescope Jeff isn't that like a
viewport yes it is
I get yeah I guess yeah so I mean you're
taking a sub you know you're just kind
of zooming into one particular at this
guy
yeah it's circular usually the
boundaries are circular at least on I
don't know about more digital telescopes
maybe the boundaries are not circular
anymore
where do you capture the image on if
it's circular
your eye
well if you're taking an image you know
it's going to be a rectangular region
you know that's what I figure
right but so my question would be okay
so let's assume you're using you're
doing astrophotography of this image as
we see it here right then
and we got a telescope in a particular
direction the telescope has a certain
magnification
it will then carve out a rectangular
region from this is that correct
is it just cookie cutter Carver
rectangular region out or is it does it
then reproject it again
well it's a bit like a Geo when we make
a map right we are going into a small
region
and then simply
helping it out exactly
once we go into very very small regions
the projection doesn't matter very much
all projections are good to behave in
the same way yeah
it's when you are looking at the whole
thing that that
so so we've got the additional thing of
where are you pointing your telescope
and in the case of spherical image and
the stuff we feed into VR we're just
going to give them the whole enchilada
and then it's a question of you know
what the you know what the actual
um mems or whatever they are that sense
Direction uh or you know
that that's how we pick out
which part of this Sky image we're
looking at right
yep
okay so let's come back now to the
Observer question
so
the question is
where and when are you
and that Horizon piece remind me what
some of the other choices for Horizon
are
so the main ones the traditional ones
are equatorial ecliptical Galactic and
Horizon
and then all of them have modern
versions depending on whether they
follow the procession of the Earth or
not or things like that so there are
kind of
modern versions
okay but hold on so the Observer you
need to say you you need a point where
you're and you need a frame is that
right exactly so this defines this
defines the three access centered at
this point
okay yeah that gets the whole frame
right the point in the frame or it but
there's a there's a sign to the frame as
they're not the Horizon there is you're
looking only
at the at the up Sky not at the down
Earth so if I was in space for example
okay then I have a different situation
then I don't want Horizon do I because
in space
you know you can see in all directions
right
and and for example Horizon will always
require a location or in our body
um and some computations if you try to
do them with uh I don't know you just
specify here the Earth Horizon will say
no I do want the allocation okay so I
want to see can we try this Astro
Graphics try new line I want to see the
Astro Graphics as seen by pioneer 10.
that should work right
we should be able to see the the sky
actually this is a really cool thing we
should be able to see that the
configuration of stars as seen by binary
10. I I'm not sure well the
configuration of planets rather will be
even more interesting
um
[Music]
I'm not sure the I can do this because I
don't think I have a way of specific
finance an extra position where the
Pioneer is
it it should be possible I just don't
have it yet yeah okay okay fine but so
every satellite and every deep space
probe should have a you know that should
be an astral position right we haven't
we have a helio quartz property that's a
list of triples right and it should be
possible to extract it from there but
for example something along the lines of
what you are thinking about is I think
this one
so this is the icrs is one of these
modern frames which is centered at the
solar system Body Center
and because the solar system Body Center
is just outside the Sun
looking from here we see the earth now
there
right and the Sun is huge because we are
just very close to the Sun what happens
if we're very close to the Earth does
the Earth does the Earth look big then
if we're looking from the Moon well the
size is not correct the sun would
actually be way bigger than what we're
seeing here
um so why don't you make it correct
but there is the question of how much to
enlarge these things because if we are
always correct to the size
then then in most cases things are
points okay so we're probably going to
need an option to control that exactly
so there is a Formula which which I'm
still playing with which controls this
this balance between you are very close
to it so you want the real size you are
very far from it you want it enlarged
yeah it makes sense for example Neptune
Neptune is Tiny so you don't even see a
point here
or Pluto which is the same but not a
point well but by time you mean it has
low magnitude
yes I mean it's not visible the naked
eye
and and if we compute the um the actual
angular size it's super tiny
well maybe we need something where there
is a color a gray color for example that
we show objects that wouldn't be visible
I mean you know no stars are gray
you know I mean you haven't Torres there
which is some kind of yellowish color
there I notice and um uh which is all
well and good but in other words you
could have a thing that represents this
is a fakely puffed out thing and it's
gray
you know what I'm saying
I mean honestly you could use you could
use gray you could use green because no
stars are green
perhaps the names perhaps a planet
should have a different color in the
name
perhaps so yes I think that would be a
nice idea or some different rendering I
mean
you could also give their
um astronomical symbol right before the
word that would be another way to show
them to distinguish them
might be a kind of nice
again there's design questions so please
Aubry this is please collect this piece
of design questions
understand
okay it was really hard to hear still
I'll play around with a little bit more
how do you deal with something like
Andromeda just curious the Andromeda
Galaxy
yeah or the constellation
the Galaxy
traditionally they're traditionally
they're drawn as ellipses uh I've even
done some mock-ups so I don't have them
ready for this so they're not
incorporated into this at all we
actually have
um uh position angle uh and major and
minor axes for most of the galaxies or
at least the bright ones anyway so in
theory we do have the data to
render them in their correct orientation
and size most of them are very tiny at
this scale the Andromeda galaxy would be
visible
but I don't know how much data we want
to have like
shipped in product so it's just ready to
be rendered and how much you have to
query from entity values and Sanity
values kind of slow
to get all that data in real time what
are we talking about I mean if we if if
you have galaxies okay so here's another
point
you know I'm looking at the at the sky
in a particular you know orientation at
some moment at some point I want to see
the cosmic microwave background I want
to see all the way back you know 14
billion years or whatever at some point
I might want to see what are the
galaxies in this direction
am I making sense yeah
and I mean
you know what you're showing here
where's the center of our galaxy it's
presumably over there on the puffy thing
yeah over there over there by Ontario
between yeah between Pluto and Antares
there yep but we're not mocking the
center of the Galaxy
not yet we're good but
I think we should Market in some way
and um okay all right let's come back to
the Astro Observer question
mm-hmm
um
so the initial thing is a frame
it's a it's in general a signed frame
correct
uh yes
so there's a
um
all right
so again in space what is the frame that
you're going to use
I'm confused I mean and why is there
you're at a point
there in a space there are always frames
defined by the distant stars and for
example this icls Frame
is uh the international Celestial
reference system which plays a bit of
the role of the itlf in geography and
this is a frame that is fixed with
respect to distance Stars okay fine but
that that's an all the way around frame
that doesn't have a oh you can't look
down type frame because on the earth The
Horizon frame has a you can't look down
feature doesn't it
yes though it's typically in astronomy
to consider the Earth is transparent and
so to present this type of
plotting which you see the
down to
okay but the circular one that we had
doesn't include down the circular one
was cut off at the edges of the circle
correct if you do the Lambert if you do
the Lambert Azimuth one yeah you're
you're right so so when you say Horizon
when you say asteroids over our Horizon
what do you mean do you mean one that is
cut off that one there
what do we mean here you mean the court
you mean the coordinates are the
coordinates are measured in altitude and
Azimuth is basically what you mean
angle above the Horizon is asthma or
altitude okay listen listen The Observer
should presumably specify do you want to
see down or not
that shouldn't be something that's
implicit or it has all those weird
things hanging off the edges and things
that's implicit in the astral projection
that's a feature of the Observer is it
not
whether the Observer is a is a you know
eyes on all sides of its head alien or
whether it's you know whether it's us
standing on the ground or something
is that true or not
I think it would be more like a
visualization thing right so we could
have an astro styling like in Geo and
then we defined all these various colors
Style no no but that's not the point the
point that I'm making is
do you see down right well in this
picture you are cutting off things below
the below the Horizon correct yeah yeah
okay fine so what I'm saying is how do
you specify that is Astro Observer Arrow
Horizon telling you to do that or not
I think that's a styling thing not a not
an observational physics correct
correct because a lot of times you'll
observe in the altitude asthma Horizon
system but you may want to turn the
ground on or off
many programs will allow you to turn the
ground on or off
okay but it shouldn't be styling we
should not call it styling it's a very
fundamental thing whether you include
I think that should be part of the
Observer thing I think it should be
something packaged together with Horizon
and it should be Horizon you know up
only or something but I mean this is
something that is the same freedom in
the second argument of Astro position
and so if we include things here that
are not useful in Astro position it's
it's
simply well okay
okay but here it's an option in astral
position it's not an option so that
doesn't work for me I mean in other
words this
okay we could have parameters here
additionally to those that
as the position astral position does it
a disaster position have a fraction or
not yes it does
so yeah so this is so these are the
collection of frames we have
and then these are the parameters that
currently Astro position takes
so it doesn't work the same way where's
the here in astral position
it it's it's also here it's the location
you can give it not exactly
exactly this design sort of shorthand
notation these three are so important
that they are understood in a different
way
okay
so you said the other one the other name
for this in some position was Celestial
system
yep
very obscure name
I think it was something etai suggested
you know a funny thing here which is
fundamental to astronomy is the time
right there's no such thing in in our
geography yep right or Graphics you know
it's just not there this time there was
another thing with graphics
um
let's see
so
if you just object to the name Observer
what about Astra viewer
no because that's the that's it's not a
that's not the thing I'm objecting to I
think I'm objecting to is this is
defining there is a whole giant
space-time thing laid out there and
you're saying there's a now there's a
here there's a where are you looking at
this giant sort of uh
sort of it looks to me like all the
other options are dealing with
projections like astral range Astrid
projection
that's astral range talks about
coordinates in the projected space right
looks to me yeah
yeah it does
yeah this is saying this is saying
in
Astro Observer is a little bit more like
astral range because astral range is
telling you of the whole Sky what part
of it are you looking at am I correct
yes that's correct
okay so Astro Observer is saying
and
what coordinate system am I going to use
and by the way what part of space-time
the now and here and so on am I looking
at
so this is from where you are looking at
and these are angle angle ranges in this
Frame
to to look at
yeah
I mean this follows I've tried to follow
Geographics
is okay the only one that isn't working
is Astro Observer you yes that's a new
one with respect to jio yes
yes in the effectively you are always
doing mapping from the center of the
Earth
okay what you've got there is you've got
okay what is it called in astronomy what
is is frame is that it's called yes
reference frame and reference systems
are the two names that are typically
used
so in recent decades a difference has
appeared between reference frames and
reference systems and that's for example
why we have itrf and not itrs
yes the distinction is that the
reference system is the ideal
reference that you're talking about and
the reference frame is the realization
and so every few years there is a
technological better realization of the
same reference system
and that's why we have it atf00 idrf05
so what is this thing asked Observer it
is a reference system
it's a reference system effectively yes
it's a
so this part is a reference system so
the the event in a space from which you
are looking at and the orientation of
the axis and then there are physical
modifications uh this one as you can see
they're in light deflection by the Sun
or aberration
so in astronomy it's very typical that
and those those are the things that
makes it a reference frame rather than
system
the non-idealness of it
no so here in Astro I'm just referring
to the icrs but that is I
crf1
icrf2 icrf3 okay
and those are progressively more and
more precise I'm just using the last one
but they're more precise because they
get better gravitational time delays and
God knows what else right exactly but
um vlbi measurements things like that
um
but these things
that you know the aberration the
notation and all that that sounds like
models that can be improved over time
yeah
yeah
so this is a model that improves our
time indeed
um these this is a Formula that makes
light appear to come from a different
place when you are observing it while
moving right and some it's a formula
that is implemented there and people
worry about how much is that
contributing to my measurement so you
can activate it or deactivate it to see
how much of a difference that makes
Okay so
Astro viewing system
Astro I hate reference system because
just such a weird you know meaningless
thing
um Castro Center would that make sense
doesn't make any sense at all no there
is already a Master Center
you can say Astro Center is this star
astral range three degrees
and that imitates a telescope
well I think astral reference system is
the least bad
[Music]
I hate the fact that we've got things
like refraction and aberration in there
I mean we could go it's a bit obscure
Astro system or something
and Method something related to us from
method observation method no because
where you are is hardly a method
yep
I mean maybe there's two options here
maybe there should be two different
options
you know Astro effects and that's where
you put in you know polar motion
refraction Etc et cetera et cetera
should have
Astro bass and Astro effects
see what I'm saying where Astro Bass
I mean I kind of like Astro Bass
for the here and now so to speak
I see what you mean I think I was trying
to keep the same objects here and there
I'm aware yeah
I know I know I know
what's thesis coordinate system so once
you have defined a frame you can say I
want to spherical coordinates or
Cartesian coordinates or cylindrical
coordinates
or projected coordinates okay but but
having Astra effects as a separate
argument I mean as an option the Astra
position seems okay to me
you know we have some default and then
if you want to switch on and off
aberration you can do that with an
option
I see
and then what would happen here is that
Astro base
would become also an option to astral
position
giving we can visit via this second
argument or the option yes
I'm kind of liking astrobase but can we
justify the first element
and that would be just a noun here or
also the orientation
I mean look
to me astral based astral frame Astro
effects are three separate things
are they not I mean that Horizon thing
is a frame so all those right
the the part of the orientation it's an
orientation
they are different but they are related
for example The Horizon must be defined
by where
so they have to go together because this
Horizon is depending on on where you are
I understand that's the default faster
base so
look the
I mean I understand the frame needs a
base point
I still think it should be three options
Astra frame Astro bass Astro effects
that's my suggestion now let's say we
did that for Astro graphics
now your concern is what do we do for
astral position
right
[Music]
okay
we've got the frame
I mean it's interesting that frame in
mechanical systems include the base
points I mean you need to you need to
know where the coordinate system is
well so do you hear
no but you seem to
that seems like the only orientation
what do you call frame here
no
it's it's got the base point it's that's
the here yeah no no it doesn't hear you
know it's just there but if you were
splitting them you were splitting up
frame is only being orientation yes
because most of the time we are boring
Earth dwellers
that's why it doesn't matter much
because here there's a you know
for many purposes
here
you know in a mechanical system
you know whether the bulldozer is there
or down the street or whatever you have
to Define that
well yeah but but you know like in a row
you know like a robot with robots
obviously you need to say where it is
but in this case there's an obvious
canonical sense of where it is which is
where you are okay yeah right so
therefore you do not need that to be as
prominent because there is a totally
obvious default
and a different default is well if I
were in a spacecraft what would I see is
a completely different and much more
obscure thing
right and I mean I assume by the way
that you can put telescopes in the here
position and it correctly picks up their
geopositions
we can do that it
you know if I put Keck telescope or
something there
should work and anything that this idea
Position will work if it has a position
property in the world okay so okay my
proposal would be it is astral frame
Astro based Astro effects all right and
what we do here
in this is that the default
is that that frame is just the frame
it's you could specify an astral frame
Arrow or you could specify it as a naked
value of the frame option
and if you want the other things like
I mean from where you are looking will
always be very important this these
three you keep all the time specifying
them
yeah I know but they're different things
[Music]
they're different things
well I mean maybe you can just have a
triple there
and and that that's the or you can
specify it with options so you either
have a triple that's frame comma the
elements of astrobase
but now look in astral distance you were
saying
oh gosh
in astral distance you don't need the
here but you do need the now
yes I think in a study stance what I was
planning is because you always have to
specify who is looking at whom
so I think I got it wrong so it's astral
distance of I don't know Mars
Mars
but this bug with the thing showing in
the magnified view
uncentered is really annoying okay go
ahead now and then I think yeah I mean
the Horizon here doesn't play any role
but currently it's needed so I can say
now
now plus yes yes I I Rely quantity
three years
and then here
you say where
um
what do you mean by where
this is a mess
so these this is saying give me the the
distance observes by Jupiter so this is
the distance of the light travel from
Mars to Jupiter observed by Jupiter on
this date
I understand I understand I think that's
a mess
oh I I think I just precisely one that
requires a allocation
so here we we place any frame compatible
with this location I know but I just
think it's a mess I think it's a mess I
think we've got to have an astral
distance where you can just give two
objects at a time here I mean the nice
thing would be
as the distance of Mars and then Jupiter
comma date and it says this is the date
of jupiterated
yes yes dated yeah I I agree with that
right so
that deals with the date
now I have to say
you could have the dated rapper around
either of the objects and if the objects
are five light years apart that's going
to matter
yes
I mean she's good
exactly there is always the emission
problem and the observation problem
dated yeah
yeah so that's good that we have dated
that we can put the date wrapper around
either of them
and I mean we have to be able to say
in in the case of
um geo-distance it's symmetric doesn't
matter which you know who's coming who's
going in this case we have to we'll have
to Define I know which way around it
should be I mean I I I kind of think
it's from two
like in travel distance and travel
directions it's from two right
am I making sense yes yes because it's a
list of why do you think it's symmetric
geo-distance is symmetric the distance
from New York to Los Angeles is no no
I'm just saying here if you dated Mars
no it's not symmetric it's not symmetric
okay not symmetric because because the
distance
you know things could move in the time
that you're defining a date and and
they've got to define the coordinate
system you're using about what that you
know what the simultaneous surface is
yeah exactly
okay but but so
Okay so we've got some solution here for
Astrid distance so let's go back and
look at
um
I mean an interesting question
is let's say I want to do astral
graphics
of the position of Mars
on 20 days through the year
yes
then presumably what I should be able to
do is to say Astro Graphics of dated
Mars comma block dated Mars commodore
Etc
at which point my
Astro base
really shouldn't even be there
so this is this example
in which we take Mars on
this number of weeks
like 50 different weeks yeah and then we
plot them here
on a map
they can today so this is a current map
so the sun will will appear where it is
right now but we simultaneously place
all these
positions so we see retrograde motion
here for example
okay but your point then is that to say
in Astro Graphics dated of Mars
inside the Astro Graphics as part of The
Primitives does or does not make sense
well I think it does yes in this case
[Music]
okay let's go back out let's go back out
to him I am pretty certain that this
thing about breaking these into three
options is the right thing so let's just
see what
the I mean in Astro Graphics there's no
problem in breaking them into three
options is that a true statement
I think it feels more natural in Astro
Graphics yes because it's based on on
options
right okay yeah let's look at astral
position
so asterisk distance again
we
in astral distance Astro base
we are not wanting to put in there as a
instead I mean Astro distance should
probably support Astro distance of Mars
comma Astro bass Arrow Sun for example
potentially
so the options are the ultimate thing
and there are shorthand notations that
are arguments
am I making sense
yes though in other cases in which we
have an argument and an option so far
the argument always wins when you
specify both
okay that's fine then that can be that
way
I'm not defining that here if that's
what we've done that's what we should do
okay so so let's go back again
to um
uh astral position okay
um by the way I'm very impressed with
all this functionality and this is very
it's all great anyway
um and I want to show you an example
that doing like yeah
um
the okay
so
I think what you're saying is
in astral position
we probably should have the possibility
of having that second argument be a list
that has here now and
the name of the you know the the name of
the frame
and we probably should put the little
Adam in any order because we there's a
string there so this is that we kind of
know what they are yeah and and that's
just you know it's just the the frame
bucket so to speak or the or the or the
reference system bucket but otherwise we
separate them out as astral frame Etc
that is my proposal
and if we had to give that argument
because we want to get the celestial
because we want to get the coordinate
system you could say automatic and then
you give a bunch of options faster a
position
actually that's an input in output I
could canonicalize to effectively what
that is right now
what do you mean what there is right now
you remember the frame
in which everything gets collected into
a third argument
into a into a second argument
rather than the Astro effects also yeah
yeah that's fine to connect
canonicalization is good but then you've
got to do things like Define the order
of the Astro effects and so on
if you're really going to canonicalize
yes it's just to have a canonical form
no I agree I agree because our
performance good but I'm just saying
you've got to decide that it's
aberration first then refraction then
whatever
um
I think there's some trickiness if you
say option of Astral position comma
Astra effects what do you get and
perhaps you should be able to perhaps
that should re-extract it
slightly tricky
[Music]
okay but show me the example you wanted
to show
[Music]
it's this one so
um
so let's look first at this image which
is the image
of of adding tones observation in 1919
in which he was looking at this
solar eclipse and he was looking at this
very six stars in the constellation of
Taurus
okay is that the actual image yes this
is one of their images but this is
considered one probably the best of of
the images he took okay there there were
actually two Expeditions so this is one
he wasn't one of them and that's the one
I'm going to use here
okay
so so this is the date of the
observation I mean we can get it from
solar eclipse
roughly and we know that he was in in
principle Island
so these Stars in our collection of
stars in Jeff's collection have these
names so D6 stars are D6 systems
and once they're just in a podcast
catalog that weren't named in
arrington's Time
um I guess they were named already well
then why are they called hip whatever
that's that's a much more I mean that's
obviously Parker's catalog number
what were their names in addington's
time
uh off the top of my head I don't know I
mean I mean any given star has usually
many different names so no I understand
that I understand it but I'm asking the
following question that
okay but if it was called upstrong Tori
and we're naming it
parker7364 is that really the right
thing to do or should we canonicalize to
its more common name that's all I'm
asking we can definitely pick something
more common
um I'm kind of surprised that a star
that showed up in that catalog is
actually known by hippar so I'll have to
look at that exactly exactly that's why
I'm saying that's probably hipparco this
is like our fallback usually I
understand that's exactly what I was
that's exactly what I thought was the
case in that problem advised right okay
compute their equatorial positions
right so this is just to place them in
the map so this is Astro position
computing
Computing the positions of these Stars
the six of them in
in in that sorry I have to change this
but this these are just the positions of
the Stars in in this day and then this
is a manipulate showing
um I have this sorry
if this defaults which I don't have
so let me repeat this quickly
you have saved definitions goes to True
is that going to mess you up
oh let's see no not if you remember
okay
so now this is time so I'm going to look
at six hours to 18 hours so 24 hours
around that date that we picked here so
this this starts these four are these
four so this is just rotated
a different frame and this star is this
Star by the way it might be nice to
actually get the frame the same I mean
just just to make sure we can do that
from The Horizon from princip island or
whatever presumably he had its feet on
the ground so to speak and that defined
his orientation
exactly the telescope could have been
rotating on an equatorial axis to track
it though so it's like things are going
to be on a circular
I just want to make a point about that
in terms of Astro graphics
some of these things like telescope
images is reflected you know
um or the telescope is on some
equatorial Mount or whatever else we
should have a nice way to parametrize
those things with respect to what astral
Graphics actually shows
okay okay I mean show me the
gravitational effect
so so this is this is what happened so
here we see so that's the sun that's the
Moon that comes at some point
and and so we see we can see when the
eclipse happened right yep but the Stars
seem to be very fixed here yes the the
stars are that's why I'm using the
equatorial frame right because in in
that frame the stars are fixed yeah okay
I understand
so the the thing is that uh no no the
the the effect is absolutely tiny so we
get more or less that the moment in
which he took the picture was 1.1 hours
after the day that we chose so this this
manipulate is just to select the time
because for example
further down
the Sun Touched this star but of course
this was not visible anymore yeah yeah
right
right but these other moment was about
six or something like that right
so now we compute this function
which is the position of this star which
is this one
and with or without separation yeah
exactly cool and so when this thing came
very close to the disk of the sun that's
when there was the peak in that
difference
exactly what he observed is about one
second
which is this moment right one point
hours is when the when the eclipse
occurred but he knows he knew it was a
one over r RB in the distance to the
center of the Sun so if you compute the
moment in which the sun touches the star
it's it's about 6.5 hours then we get
the famous number that is in all books
the 1.75
seconds
which is not what he observed exactly he
couldn't have serve that
right I mean the 1.5 75 would would have
been when the the star touched sorry
when the Sun so if you've been lucky and
the eclipse would happen on a star field
that contained a star that was really
close to the disc of the sun then he
would have had a bigger effect
exactly but but I mean it wasn't much of
a difference but I mean perhaps he could
have gone to some planes play place in
the ocean in which the perspective could
have been better but of course he
couldn't take a good picture
yeah right
very interesting
so that Island I mean if you if you uh
okay just for for the fun of you know
the blog post you might write about this
I mean you should figure out whether
there's any spit of land somewhere you
know whether the ocean is way too deep
in that part of the world for that to be
any you know I have no idea what princip
island is
um so something interesting this this
part here over 1.75 is completely
spurious so this is when the when the
star is is behind the Sun so this is
Computing something there
because the formula is just the distance
from the start to the center of the Sun
it predicts something bigger but this is
not visible
that's the y-axis here I'm sorry what's
the y-axis
this is the deviation in our second time
oh the y-axis
deviation is three times minutes versus
no no no no no no no no no no no no it's
the distance
the deflection of Light by the Sun
that the vertical axis is the amount of
deflection
in Arc seconds
sorry
and and the x-axis is the time in hours
right so notice that the the size of the
Suns is about 2 000 Arc seconds so
measuring one is quite a thing yeah it's
probably not super complete nonsense
this is this is this is the cautionary
tale for those of us who have because
you know and
I modeled it not this particular thing
isn't the thing but there are other
subtle effects that one has to measure
and you have to have a experimentalist
who's who's um you know unfortunately
it's not it's not a purely objective cut
and dried question sadly all right we
we're gonna have to wrap this meeting
and I think we're going to schedule
another one of at least the same lengths
um but in the last couple of minutes
what do we have that we can look at
so this is another cool example which is
the distance between the Sun and the
Earth in miles and you see it changing
in real time huh
that's really cool
or this one is precession
by the Earth and the moon because I see
the Earth and the moon as a dynamic
would you go back up and then just
re-recompute that with the afternoon
I know what is your feet
sort of miles
oh boy wait a minute how can that be
right
oh I see I see I see I see you need to
do it oh I see I see I see I see that's
that's counting in feet so it's it's
moving
so we really need to do minus the mean
distance or something
oh I see
yeah but but you get a feeling of of the
speed of change
you know
wow
amazing
um well sorry show me the equinox
oh yes so this is procession so this is
this is the equinox so this uh
intersection between the ecliptic plane
and the equatorial plane and this is the
new modern uh uh axis of of something
that moves much less and so the angle
this is angular separation between both
and so this is what the
prosection of the equinoxes is
proceeding
so it takes 2000 26 000 years to give a
full round
there was 23 000 years there's all these
different Cycles I forget is that right
26
um I think it's 25 700. okay okay
yeah but did you see here that how the
Equinox is moving
and so in in the 20 so many of the
suggestions here on our live stream one
is why don't we catalog astronomical
events like black hole mergers Supernova
I think we have Supernova explosions
don't we I said do we have super over
explosions we have we do have some that
the set hasn't been updated in quite a
while but we do have a set of entities
but those entities have both a position
and a Time
well they yeah they're they're typically
in a host Galaxy that has a right
assistant declination so yeah they have
right Ascension and declination and uh
distance is usually known I think no no
no no no and Jeff we now have Astro
position we should be returning the
astral position in space and time of a
supernova explosion
you see what I'm saying
yeah not that we have to look through 17
different properties to find the place
and time you see what I'm saying yes no
host galaxies no whatever and suddenly
for Black Hole mergers it would be
really nice since there's a finite
number of them to just have the um uh to
have it be the case that you can plot on
the sky you know where have all the
black hole mergers been what happened
what were the black hole mergers last
month platinum on the sky
does that make sense we should be able
to do that yeah but we need some kind of
a data feed because probably people are
going to be interested in the most
recent ones
I recently mean it happened three
billion years ago
some
the
but it's recent as far as we're
concerned yes uh
the um
uh another comment from X
X something on a live stream is about
generating videos and frames
and manipulates and so on yeah I mean
that wasn't too hard to generate right
that that picture of the I mean it
should just be a manipulator and Astro
graphics with the time
right that should be what you need to
make a and then you should be able to
turn that into a um an animation video
just directly and straightforwardly
correct yes so I have some examples here
of uh let's see
let's see if this works
so of course I think this will dovetail
with other functionality in that we want
to take basically manipulate and instead
of you manipulating them because you can
rarely manipulate more than one slider
simultaneously with one hand
that you can coordinate moves and make
movies that way you know what I'm saying
it's like mostly but but
the most important thing here is the one
parameter which is time sure yeah
and I think making an animation video in
that case it should just work basically
right yes I I'm I'm still I'm now
wandering in this Astro bass thing maybe
we should even break it into Astro bases
the position Astro time or something is
the is the date
because often you just want to change
the date
and nothing else
so why are you messing around with the
with the position as well
well the way I see myself using it is
because these
um industrial position for example
because this the second argument is
quite flexible you can put it there
and it will understood it will
understand it immediately that
the time just stick the time
yeah it's fine did I say the time the
here or acquisition and it will take Now
by default
or the frame and it will take here now
by default well actually now each frame
has a default for example I know these
ones are centered at the solar system
Body Center so each frame has a default
location
that's fine right so you give those so
fine so I mean
so the issue there is that sort of do
anything option you want some name for
that for these other functions as well
you want something where you can use the
same packaging for the other functions
and I think
you know where where you the other
functions you might break apart astral
frame Etc et cetera et cetera or you
might package them all together
I still think astral bass is the least
crazy thing for packaging them together
and look if you're going to have them
packaged and in any order
um
Association
and we can place names inside
[Music]
Maybe
maybe let's think about this a little
bit more I mean okay can I get a sense
of um just in terms of the scoping of
other things we have to discuss in Astro
by the way those were really nice demos
particularly the Addington mine
um
thanks the the um
uh can I just get a scope of what else
we need to look at here so so these two
as the position astrographics are the
fundamental functions the other ones are
auxiliary so together with us to
position we have angular distance
um magnitude and distance and together
with astrographics we have its options
okay
one thing I'm a little bit confused by
[Music]
um
okay okay okay okay okay so
angular separation Astro angular
separation is the analog of Astral
distance Astro distance is the actual
by spacecraft distance
Astro angular separation is projected
okay that's an angle
um I do think it'd be really worthwhile
to like get these black hole mergers and
things like that and are there any other
events do we have gamma ray bursts all
those kinds of things
no because there's not any one catalog
there's multiple missions and so finding
a canonical Source you know there's
different events different sources take
a look let's try and figure it out
because I mean I think now now that
we've got Astro position we've got a
meaningful thing to return for all of
those different events
am I making sense
no I mean it should be the case that if
we have the Astra position if we haven't
specified correctly black hole merger
happened okay here's a here's an example
right I said this is really cool I mean
the you know we should know we know this
black hole merger we know
maybe we know it's distance I think in
most cases we do
and then what we've got is basically we
can say
what was the order of these black hole
mergers as viewed from another black
hole merger
because the astral Position will be
given in the time
for us at which that merger took place
and its coordinate position in the
universe
right well at the moment The Observers
are limited to be inside the solar
system which is where we know well the
physics of what's going on
I mean once we go outside the solar
system
their relativity is much less known
why
I mean we don't know to that Precision
but we should be able to say from you
know okay for the black hole merger that
just happened last week
what was the sequence of black hole
mergers that happened for it in the past
year
based on the ones we've seen and
obviously the order will be completely
different from the order as it is from
Earth
we would have to make some strong
assumptions like the space is nearly
flat outside the solar system things
like that no deflection of anything
Etc
well I mean we know cosmologically we
have a cosmological standard model
yes but there's no cosmology at all yeah
I mean it's going to be be outside the
Galaxy is even more complicated
and within the Galaxy I think it's
really hard because then we'd have to
have all kinds of you know gravitational
lensing around random stars and so on
that seems really hard
right
I think in in cosmological length scales
we have a standard cosmological model
and it seems not impossible to deal with
that
yes but I don't know how to merge the
relativity of the solar system which is
done with our first order post Newtonian
expansion Etc with the cosmology
that I don't think has been done
but Jose you're well equipped
I might understand how it's done but it
takes time yeah this is something to
consult with perhaps exports yes
I think some of your relatively friends
might be relevant here yeah
I mean
probably nobody has tried to do this I
mean why would they have done but but um
I guess the Gaia team is is the more
advanced in this type of thing
and and they do have long discussions
about their relativity even around the
spacecraft itself
which spacecraft what the guy yeah they
have a special coordinate system defined
for Gaia
um
well we could ask him yeah that's that's
the most Advantage I've seen
hmm
okay
well very interesting
um
but we should at least get astral
positions of these you know
sort of cosmological scale events and um
yeah this course one incredibly obscure
thing right which is the astral position
at the beginning of the universe
for which we need for which we
necessarily need cosmology so I agree
that that is very hard to because
otherwise you know it's an astral
position which is in all directions at
the beginning of the universe
right
that is tough
uh so we won't ask for that this week it
happened everywhere 13.8 billion years
ago
yeah
right
but but most of these things are Point
things
um
are there Jeff maybe you know are they
actually elements in the Gaia catalog
that goes that far back
uh
the Gaia catalog is mainly focused on
things in our galaxy as far as I know
um I don't think it looked at
cosmological sources I could be wrong
about that uh its main purpose though
was to catalog structure of our galaxy
um so it mainly was measuring proper
motion and stuff of stars within our
galaxy that's not to say that the images
didn't contain images but I don't know
that they measured yeah well exciting
stuff okay I gotta go thanks guys we
should schedule another meeting and uh
see you all soon
bye for now